so inspired by coach doug duggerton or
gus duggerton or just coach doug's our
draft today is teams we would have liked
to coach for a year and it's units not
the whole team just the units so big cat
i've got the trivia question for you if
you get it right you get the first pick
here we go
uh the 85 bears beat the patriots 46 to
10 in super bowl 20. did the patriots
offense have more turnovers or rushing
yards in the game more turnovers
oh no trick question seven rushing yards
six turnovers it was close oh that is a
tricky question six six turnovers by the
way uh get on my level
i had seven picks last night get on my
level and super bowl super bowl 20 is
the prime example and i think we've
talked about this before of what happens
when
you root for disruption in the playoffs
and you get disruption to the super bowl
because it should have been dolphins
bears rematch the only team that beat
the bears all year dan marino and
company on a monday night in december
but the patriots beat the dolphins and i
was all in on that yeah yeah yeah let's
see the underdog win it's like oh crap
the underdog is going to get stopped now
by the bears all right i hate to take
the 85 beers yeah i hate you
i have to take the 85 bears all right i
take the 85 bears simply because you
didn't know enough 85 bears trivia i get
the 85 bears give me the 85 bears best
defense of all time
i should have known it was a trick
question i should have known it was a
trick question um yeah you have to this
is almost like the 85 bears draft uh but
i'm going a different route for my my
picks here mike
i'm going to go
with units because we're we're picking
units not teams correct so you're taking
the 85 bears defense i'm going to take
units where as a coach my job is as easy
as possible because you have a
transcendent talent that makes
everything else easy so i will start
with the 86 giants lawrence taylor
helping out and basically being like hey
you go do whatever you want
you'll make everyone else's job easy go
hat
so are you saying that it's the entire
giant's defense but your influence to
take the defense because of lawrence
taylor all right i'm talking about
making my job making my job as easy as
possible when you have a transcendent
talent on the unit
all right well there was a transcendent
talent on the 98 vikings offense and his
name was randy moss and also chris
carter why didn't you take them when you
could the 98 vikings offense without
question that offense was so good and
randy moss was so dominant as a rookie
anybody could have stood back there and
thrown the ball deep and would have
thrown 30 touchdown passes or more moss
had 17 i believe as a rookie that was a
special special offense and that's one
where you're just on autopilot just go
let the great players play great and
you're going to win games and but for
gary anderson you're going to go to the
super bowl
all right so i will uh i'll stay on the
offensive side of the ball i'll just
take the greatest uh show on turf
because that was a truly transcendent
offense randy moss was obviously
incredible best receiver all time but
the rams that the way they stunned the
football world with tory holt isaac
bruce oznasir uh hakeem ricky proll
kurt warner
that's my that is my team that that is
my uh offensive unit that i would coach
especially knowing trent greene went
down everyone cast them aside said they
were not going to be there
i'll take the rams 2 000 offense to
coach that i would be throwing the ball
all over the yard mike it would be
incredible
i i and you're absolutely right and i'm
surprised it took that long for the
greatest show-offs on turf to make it
onto this draft
did you was that was that a purpose
no i i don't know what i said the
greatest show on turf
that's not what you said
you said the great anyway show-offs on
turf
all right uh yeah and they were and they
were but they were good hey it was that
arena football experience for kurt
warner the quick drop get rid of the
ball we thought they were done we
thought it was over trent green tears
his acl in pre-season the rams had stunk
the past few years dick vermeo was on
his way out and then all of a sudden
they catch lightning in a bottle and
they win the super bowl and kurt warner
goes from bagging groceries at the
piggly wiggly to being the regular
season mvp and the super bowl mvp i
think he's the last one to do both in
the same season all right this is a
this is a big cat pick i whenever you're
on for the draft i try to come up with
something that would be kind of your
your outside the box selection and i'm
i'm leaving some good offenses and
defenses on the board to do this but i'm
doing it yes i am as sims would say
2001 patriots special teams because
playoff game against the raiders what
come on what did adam vinitari do he
makes that kick in the snow in the snow
you said coaches just sit back and let
great players do great things what do
you think the special teams coach said
to adam vinatieri i suggest you go out
and make the field goal i mean what else
can he say he makes it then he makes one
in the overtime and wins that game and
then they go to pittsburgh and i was at
that game 2001 afc championship a punt
return by troy brown 55 yarder to open
the scoring and bust the bubble of a
steelers team that thought they were
just going to punch their ticket for a
showdown with the greatest show-offs on
turf i said at that time and and a
blocked field goal return for a
touchdown later in the game and then in
the super bowl what was it what was it
an atomitary walk-off field goal to win
it all so under your definition you said
so
a unit that you just sit back and let it
do its thing the 2001 patriot special
teams delivered the championship started
the dynasty boom roasted
boom roasted that you don't boom roast
me get out of here that's not boom
roasted i actually wanted to take the uh
original the the the reason behind the
the unit meme the in all the size he's
an absolute unit uh guy if we can find
if matt casey can go find that the david
morgan hewitt that was where originally
came from that meme which you don't even
understand i'm talking gibberish to you
but to everyone else i'm making perfect
sense i will take finally uh i'll take
the super bowl box i'll take the box
simeon rice warren sapp derek brooks
rondae barber john lynch just an
incredible team with incredible talent
that defense was off the charts and they
had
multiple guys who you could just say go
out and play go out and play go out and
play go out and get the quarterback i
don't have to scheme anything up you got
this
and isn't it amazing the cliche goes
defense wins championships and two of
the all-time great defenses in nfl
history the 85 bears and the 2002
buccaneers they had one championship to
show for all that talent that they
amassed they should have both been
dynasties and i'm not i'm not saying
that to you you you were like yeah were
you in diapers then one one one
one year
you're absolutely right like defensive
do win championships but i mean you
could even throw the ravens in there too
an all-time defense that won one title
because
it's tough when you don't have an
offense for multiple years in a row when
you don't have that quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports